it's honestly something I wouldn't wish
for anybody
it's really hard but
if I've learned anything is that
communication is key to us daddies in
the Stars so we can go outside and talk
to him whenever we want Allison holker
opening up in her first TV interview
following her husband Stephen twitch
boss's tragic death we want to enjoy the
experiences that we're having we want to
have each other there to experience it
together like I think it's all about
playing with the ones that you love
still liking them and loving them at the
same time twitch died by suicide in
December I still feel like I'm like the
rest of the world where I'm still
shocked
no one's ready for that moment and
there's no one that saw this coming no
one
and that also breaks my heart too but I
feel so sad that he was so there and we
weren't
in the knowing he wanted to be the
strong one for everyone and I think that
was a little scary for him to think that
he might need to ask for help now
Allison reveals the hard conversation
she's had with the children they share
seven-year-old son Maddox three-year-old
daughter ziya and Allison's 14 year old
daughter Wesley from a previous
relationship we love the Full House and
also just like family man like honestly
they're my favorite they're my favorite
people if they just ask
when is Daddy coming back
and that's a really hard one then it'll
be like a couple weeks later like but
does he come back when he's older like
when daddy's older he'll come back but
they are a Soul Children and still
obviously want him here Allison and
twitch first met in 2010 when they
appeared on So You Think You Can Dance
and tie the knot three years later will
you marry me
yes
our love was magical yeah and it was so
real and
I think that's the hardest part about
all this the way we loved was so big and
I got 13 years with
one of the most magical humans
and I learned
oh I'm sorry
I learned so much about love and
gratitude the way we approach life is we
kind of look at life as being our
playground you know so we like to try
new things it's interesting
the word Widow
is hard and it's
never easy when you hear it
you know the first time I ever heard it
was really hard
because I was like me Allison says she
talks to her late husband every night
and finds comfort in the memories people
share of twitch which Echoes what she
said on Instagram back in February it
has been very challenging and emotional
but you guys have brought
so much hope and inspiration to us by
sharing stories and memories and moments
and different ways that Stephen impacted
your life in the wake of twitch's death
Allison is honoring his legacy launching
the move with kindness Foundation to
support mental health what I would
really love is to bring
awareness to mental health open up the
conversations but to hopefully help
people to feel comfortable asking for
that help
I really do want to make an impact on
behalf of like someone I love so much